Every year, our Muslim friends warn us
that celebrating Christmas is haram.
>> It'd be better saying
happy drinking than to say to somebody,
"Merry Christmas."
>> Christmas dinner. No, don't go to
Christmas dinner. Period.
>> And you saying Merry Christmas, saying
congratulations on your false religion.
Congratulations on your false
understanding of life. Congratulating
them on the most evil of Andu. And
asblim said, this is worse than
fornication and drinking alcohol and
killing someone.
>> Now when we wish them merry Christmas,
what are we doing? We are actually
congratulating them on the shik,
>> celebrating the feasts of non-Muslims is
totally prohibited and a major sin.
>> And every year, Mosalah gets in trouble
for wishing his fans merry Christmas.
But why shouldn't Muslims celebrate
Christmas? They have the story of the
miraculous conception and virgin birth
of Jesus right there in the Quran. Why
not celebrate the miracle?
Well, it's because according to the
Bible, Jesus is the divine son of God.
And that's the main point of the
miracle. Islam removes the main point of
the miracle so that the miracle has no
point. But that doesn't mean Muslims
shouldn't celebrate the miracle. It's a
miracle of Allah according to Islam.
Right? Why not celebrate it? Apart from
that, Muslims have an even greater
reason to celebrate Christmas. Lots of
people practice the secret Santa
tradition. The secret Santa tradition is
where everyone draws a name out of a
basket and gives a present anonymously.
Sometimes people reveal their identity
after they give the present. Sometimes
they stay permanently anonymous. All you
know is that you got a present from your
secret Santa.
Did you know that Islam has a secret
Santa? In fact, Islam has the most
spectacular secret Santa ever. Islam's
secret Santa saved all of us from being
destroyed. What an awesome gift. We
would have been annihilated, but someone
came to our rescue.
We might as well call our wonderful
benefactor Islam's secret savior.
You probably haven't heard much about
Islam's secret savior. He kind of works
behind the scenes and Muslims don't like
talking about the amazing gift he gave
us. You can contrast this with
Christianity where Christians talk about
our savior all the time. We give thanks
for our savior. Strangely, Muslims
don't. They keep his identity a secret.
I don't like secrets, especially when it
comes to someone saving me from
obliteration. I want to know who it was
so I can thank him for his generosity.
Fortunately, the Muslim sources give us
all the clues we need to identify our
hidden hero. Do you know who it is? No,
it's not Allah. As you'll see in a
moment, Islam's secret savior rescues us
from Allah. Allah is about to destroy
us, but someone saves us. Can you guess
who? No, it's not Muhammad. Muhammad
said in Sah Bkari 2753,
"I cannot save you from Allah's
punishment." Muhammad was helpless,
powerless, feeble, useless, not a hero
at all. So, who saved us from Allah's
destruction?
If you're a Christian, you might be
thinking, "It was Jesus."
Not in Islam. We'll soon see why Jesus
is Allah's supreme enemy in Islam. So,
who saved us? Before we identify Islam's
secret Santa, let me remind you that
Christmas is right around the corner. If
you're still looking for a special
Christmas gift for a special someone,
Artza has you covered. This year's
Christmas box is called Nativity Night,
and it's their most incredible box yet.
Inside there's an awesome handpainted
ceramic plate depicting the night of the
nativity, delicious foods and spices, a
beautiful handcarved olivewood nativity
ornament from Bethlehem, and other
handcrafted treasures that bring the
story of Christmas to life. Each item in
your Artsa box is handmade by local
artisans and small family businesses in
places like Bethlehem and Nazareth and
Jerusalem. So, when you sign up with
Artza, you're blessing and supporting
these artisans and families while
bringing the land of the Bible right
into your home or someone else's home.
So, help a friend or loved one
experience Christmas this year with a
box of gifts straight from the land
where Jesus walked. If you order right
now, and I mean within a day or so of me
posting this video, you should still be
able to get a Christmas box shipped. If
you're watching later, you should still
sign up with Artsa. They put together a
new box every season. Four new boxes
every year. Sign up today and share the
beauty of the Holy Land with your loved
ones. Click the link in the description
box and start getting your arts and
boxes. Now, let's get back to solving
this mystery.
Who is our secret savior according to
Islam? Well, let's think about why Allah
was going to destroy us in the first
place. Here are two hadiths from Sahim
Muslim where Muhammad says that Allah
will destroy people for not sinning. For
not sinning. Sah Muslim 66:21
Abu Aubsari reported that Allah's
messenger said if you were not to commit
sins Allah would have swept you out of
existence and would have replaced you by
another people who have committed sin
and then asked forgiveness from Allah
and he would have granted them pardon.
Sah Muslim 66:22
Abu Hurerra reported Allah's messenger
having said by him in whose hand is my
life if you were not to commit sin Allah
would sweep you out of existence and he
would replace you by those people who
would commit sin and seek forgiveness
from Allah and he would have pardoned
them. Muhammad tells his followers that
Allah wants them to sin so he can show
them forgiveness.
According to Muhammad, if we hadn't
sinned, Allah would have wiped us out
and replaced us with people who would
sin so that he could forgive them and be
most forgiving, most merciful. Allah
needs us to sin because he can't be
merciful without sinners. Allah depends
on human creatures without whom he
apparently cannot be a complete deity.
Allah has to partner with human beings
so that he can have certain attributes.
Allah is so desperate for us to sin that
he's ready to destroy us if we refuse.
This means, of course, that unless we
want to be destroyed, we need to sin. If
we don't sin, we're dead.
So why are we here right now?
Why hasn't Allah destroyed us? Allah
hasn't destroyed us because we sinned.
If we had refused to sin, Allah would
have wiped us out of existence. But we
did sin. So here we are. So sinning
actually saved us from being
exterminated.
But we didn't know that when we sinned.
We didn't know that our sins were saving
us from destruction.
So why did we sin?
Let's go to the Quran surah 2:es 35-36.
We said, "Oh Adam, dwell thou and thy
wife in the garden, and eat of the
bountiful things therein as where and
when ye will, but approach not this
tree, or ye run into harm and
transgression." Then did Satan make them
slip from the garden and get them out of
the state of felicity in which they had
been? We said, "Get ye down all ye
people with enmity between yourselves.
On earth will be your dwelling place and
your means of livelihood for a time."
Surah 7:es 19 to 22. Oh Adam, dwell thou
and thy wife in the garden, and enjoy
its good things as ye wish, but approach
not this tree, or you run into harm and
transgression.
Then began Satan to whisper suggestions
to them, bringing openly before their
minds all their shame that was hidden
from them before. He said, "Your Lord
only forbade you this tree, lest ye
should become angels or such beings as
live forever." And he swore to them both
that he was their sincere advisor. So by
deceit he brought about their fall. When
they tasted of the tree, their shame
became manifest to them, and they began
to sew together the leaves of the garden
over their bodies, and their Lord called
unto them, "Did I not forbid you that
tree and tell you that Satan was an
avowed enemy unto you?" Why did Adam and
Eve sin according to the Quran?
They sinned because Satan tempted and
deceived them.
What if Satan hadn't tempted and
deceived them?
Allah would have destroyed them for not
sinning and he would have replaced them
with people who would sin so he could
forgive them. So who saved Adam and Eve
and all their descendants from being
destroyed by Allah?
Satan, a misunderstood jin who rescued
us from Allah. And why do we sin today?
We sin because Satan continues tempting
and deceiving and misleading us. In the
Quran, after Satan was judged, he vowed
to lead people like me astray. Surah
15:39l
Satan said, "Oh my Lord, because you
misled me, I shall indeed adorn the path
of error for them, mankind, on the
earth, and I shall mislead them all."
But we shouldn't be upset about being
misled. If we didn't listen to Satan,
Allah wouldn't be able to forgive us and
he'd become enraged and destroy us. So
if Islam is true, we shouldn't hate the
devil. We should be thanking him. We
wouldn't be here without him. Our
friends, our spouses, our children,
Allah would have destroyed them all if
it weren't for good old Satan. He's our
secret savior, our hidden hero, our
undercover ally.
But there's more. If Allah wants human
beings to sin so he can forgive us, who
would his ultimate enemy be?
Someone who refuses to sin. If Muhammad
was right, Allah's greatest adversary
would be Jesus. Because Jesus just
wouldn't sin. According to Muhammad in
sah albkari 3286 Muhammad says that
Satan touches everyone who enters the
world except Jesus. He couldn't touch
Jesus. narrated Abu Hurera. The prophet
said, "When any human being is born,
Satan touches him at both sides of the
body with his two fingers, except Jesus,
the son of Mary, whom Satan tried to
touch but failed. For he touched the
placenta cover instead."
Adam sinned. Noah sinned. Abraham
sinned. Moses sinned. Muhammad sinned
like it was a sport. I guess he really
didn't want to be destroyed for not
sinning. Safety first, am I right? All
of the prophets sinned except Jesus. So
Allah can forgive all of them except
Jesus. Jesus simply wouldn't obey
Allah's command to disobey.
That's too bad because Allah tells us
what the penalty is for not sinning.
Total extermination.
Muslims claim to love God and to honor
Jesus and to despise Satan. But if we
look just a little more carefully at
what the religion teaches, we find that
their God wants us to sin and he
threatens us with destruction if we
don't. There Jesus is God's ultimate
nemesis, refusing to sin even when God
threatens him with annihilation.
The greatest hero in Islam is the devil
himself, who saves us from Allah's wrath
by convincing us to sin so that God can
forgive us because he's really, really
desperate to show some mercy.
Am I the only one who thinks there's
something funny going on here?
Well, if you can make any sense out of
these mindnumbingly silly and bizarre
teachings we keep finding whenever we
open up the Quran and the Hadith, please
let me know.
In the meantime, to all you Muslims out
there who are hearing this information
for the first time because your shakes
and imams always, always hide it from
you.
Merry Christmas. Be sure to check out my
videos, Christmas or the Cabba, which is
more pagan and the Christmas story in
the Bible and the Quran featuring Daniel
Hakikachu.
After you watch them, you'll be wishing
me merry Christmas.
>> [music]
[music]